what's going on guys national master james canton
iii here with chess.com and today we have the top
five queen sacrifices from the magician auriga
mikhail tao in this first example we actually
have him playing grand master alexi sutin so
grandmasters alexey suit is playing uh black here
and white is of course town so bishop d7 was the
last move played here in a sicilian con it's very
very aggressive as you see for white here we have
f5 i mean bishops looking like they want to do
some kind of work here the center is being open
like the king's in the center this looks like a
disaster for black hair but after f5 f5 is now
here breaking up the center breaking up all of
this and just trying to open the king's side and
rip it apart e takes f5 g takes f5 and then we
have 95 from alexis suit in here so he says all
right cool guys we got to get our pieces in the
center maybe eliminate some of the monstrous
pieces and attack that he may have coming here
then he plays 96 tao just puts the knight on e6
and stares at him extremely hard at this point
it's very scary what do you do you have to get rid
of this knight you actually can't take it this way
because of the pin but bishop takes c6 this
knight has to go so bishop takes e6 and then
he takes back on e6 himself look at the file here
i mean look at this file where hey we're taking on
f7 this is open i mean look how many arrows can
i draw here guys okay there's a lot going on a
lot going on so alexi ops in for g6 and just says
hey you have to go you have to go now it's right
to move here guys what would you actually
do here if you were towel in this position
here it is guys here it is alexis suit and
said you know what you got to move your queen
and then tao looked at him grabbed his cree
grabbed his queen and then just took the knight
and hit the clock sat back real smooth and the
game was over now he actually really didn't do
that but he felt that queen takes c5 and then d
takes e5 guys first off look at this beautiful
queen sacrifice the queen is just sacrificed for
a knight not two rooks not anything else for a
knight and actually some uh some play here maybe
even some mating attacks i'm also hitting a rook
here so you literally have to take this queen you
only have a choice why do you even think about it
you just have to take because he took your knight
here now after d take c5 we have e takes f7 as
the rook and the pawn work very well together
and now the bishops are going to do their job
because now they're ready on an open board the
bishops are ready to do their thing if king 2fa
made on the move have a nice day and if he goes
this way he jumps right into a discovery that
actually ends this way due to engine analysis
this is the best line to take rick takes
rook f8 and then king d7 bishop f5 with a double
check and everything's hanging you you might as
well just push the queen and the knight off
the board you don't even need them any longer
bishop to f5 king to c6 bishop e4 and the only
move here is knight to d5 this hurts this hurts
this is a family channel let's just get this off
the screen already guys this is over we have so
much material here and of course everything else
is going to fall at mate soon to follow here now
of course the game ended right here guys after e
takes f7 because he was like you know what i've
had enough i had enough i know what you're gonna
do people are watching i don't want any more of
this and the game ended right here and this is
example one of the top five queen sacrifices
of uh mikhail tao now let's move on to example two
now in this next example we have milko bobasoft
versus mikhail tao in 1958 tao's playing with the
black pieces and the king's indian we have queen
e5 as the last move here just trying to open up
this side of the board as much as possible and
of course have our pieces aim this way play for
counter play his king is castle this side whoever
gets to the king first on opposite side castles is
going to win he knows this so after king b1 and of
course i always play king b1 kind of thing b5 is
now here so now rook b8 may be a thing capturing
opening the file trying to open the diagonal here
and go from a now this next move by milko is very
interesting and very strong and you see this is a
common theme knight to d5 guys he plays knight to
d5 here against tau and tao has a choice here
well of course do we retreat retreat to d8 and
defend the pawn or do we move the queen or do
we take here on d2 or do we play b4 what do we
actually do here guys now when you're playing town
think about this when you are playing as tao here
i want you guys to find a move pause the video if
you need to but when you're playing like this you
have to remember that this is tau so you have
to even consider moves like queen takes a2 that
makes no sense at all but of course it is tau the
magician from riga half man half everything else
so we do have to see and calculate these kind of
moves what would you actually play with black here
here's the move tal actually picked up his piece
he actually stared at him he stared at bulbasaur
and played knight takes d5 hit the
clock folded his arms and just sat there
with a very weird stare knight takes d5 is on
the board guys he is sacrificing his queen like
it's nothing let's see exactly what we get for
it we actually get three pieces here or three
three points we took a knight he takes my queen
he gets nine now okay we get another three points
we'll say like three point two three and
a half the bishop is slightly better okay
whatever we'll give him three and a half
points there and then now we actually not
taking anything else because he can move the
rook which he does and after he moves the rook
here we only get a pawn so that equals to what
maybe at at the highest seven and a half points
maybe seven point two seven points here not a
lot of points here we actually missed off by
two points because he took a queen so that's like
not equally out but it actually does in this kind
of position here because of the counter play that
you get in in addition to the pawns if we look at
white's pieces here they're all locked in steel
they're not doing anything and ours are pretty
active not that these aren't extremely active this
rook and his knight but they were about to be and
let's see what happens rook takes c4 he gets rid
of it pawn takes and then knight to uh c1 here
let's fast forward some moves here to see the
play so we can move to the next example rook
to b8 bishop's ac4 and knight to b6 hitting the
bishop being very active here watch out how tao
puts all of his pieces on the side of the board
where all the action is guys on the side of the
board where all of the action is he plays c4 make
sure we open the file i mean he's on the defense
here every single move look at this beautiful
move here c3 is coming knight to c4 is a follow-up
man so strong so he plays queen to d3 now we take
on b2 now we have holes around your king here
and then knight to d4 bishop d7 and watch us swing
the pieces in look at every piece that we own is
in this attack this is how you attack like a
magician bishop to b3 knight e4 we're going to
do knight to c3 check so he gets rid of it bishop
takes knight to b3 hey just keep the threats
rolling rook to c3 queen takes bishop takes b3
takes and here we go nice move here we're actually
threatening this but we're also threatening other
things as well like discoveries so if king takes
we actually have a check here there may be
better checks but this is just the easiest
check right out of the bat here we literally just
win the queen back and we're up decisive material
here but uh with that being said the last move
was queen to a3 not even sure what he's doing
here i think he's just trying to stop this but the
end of the day he's still losing after rook check
then he's instead of taking with the pawn guys he
actually takes with the rook and then king 282 and
that's made on the move guys mate on the move wow
what a beautiful checkmate you don't see that very
often right and this was example number two of
the top five queen sacrifices from the magician
of riga mikhail tao now let's move on to example
number three now this next example is hans hyokim
heck versus mikhail tao back in 1962 this is
a very famous queen sacrifice guys now if you
have seen this before then this is a joy for you
this is a reminder if you haven't seen this before
then i highly recommend you pause the video and
see what you can do here it's actually white to
move right now guys as we reach a queen's indian
uh position a caspar variation queen's indian is
what happened in this opening and now we get to
a very very sharp position at a crossroad roads
where my queen on a4 is attacked my knight is
attacked on c4 there are some problems here so we
need to address it but also this is hanging on f6
so what do you actually do here guys like to move
here's what tau did tao was feeling very great
that day and he looked up he looked down he looked
around the room and then he thought about life
and he said you know what he didn't even think
about it he just took the knight he takes f6 he's
gonna take it we got enough play i see everything
e takes f6 here it is guys a spectacular queen
sacrifice watch what's about to happen next b
takes a4 okay so now we have a queen here this is
what he does i mean he sacrifices queens in his
sleep b takes a4 and f takes g7 now we're hitting
the rook here we're threatening to actually take
on g6 too as well maybe i mean rookie one's coming
like we got some serious compensation here and
also look at the king king is not really looking
too good on spaces he has king d7 these pieces
are virtually out of the game whoa like and then
you stop and look and understand the compensation
this could be very bad for black rook to g8 on the
board here then a spectacular follow-up move here
guys many players would play what move here i'm
sure you're thinking and if you aren't thinking
you should probably think here and stop pause
the video what would you actually play as white
but here rookie one right rookie one seems like
a natural move especially if you're just playing
quickly ricky won you just play rookie one tower
was like a bishop f5 and be live bishop f5 what
a move beautiful guys this seals the deal on the
spot i don't have to win the queen with the rook
i can win a queen with my bishop so if he takes
this this bishop here queen takes f5 we have
knight to d6 jack and we come back and we're doing
great actually we have so much so much that we can
do here so much potential maybe even rookie seven
sometimes in certain lines but uh bishop to f5
beautiful move here now at the bishop at five we
have knight takes h4 he says i'm just going to get
rid of it it's time to get rid of this piece
so after bishop takes e6 then uh bishop to a6
and knight to d6 from tao king e7 bishop to c4 and
now we're not losing any material as we're able to
take care of everything everything's defended
you take my knight i take your bishop you take
my bishop i take back these pawns look crazy here
it's just not looking the best actually i mean and
white's white's going to definitely do some damage
here just because of the fact that king's in the
center this knight is kind of out of play it's
not really good rick takes g7 and there's g3 here
g3 from the night now of course there's many
many moves here guys um and tal went on to win
this game guys but it's the example part here they
got very wild that i wanted to show you guys i was
so excited to show you guys this one if you've
never seen it before instead of just retreating
guys this will get your mind in in the realm of
the magician himself you don't always have to
move a piece if it's threatened now of course you
will lose many games if you don't do that but at
the same time you can win mini games if you think
outside the box or inside the box or inside tiles
box or a head or whatever b takes a four and an
f takes g f g seven and rig the g8 and bishop
f5 beautiful display here guys after b5 there's
pawn takes f6 he didn't even think about it of
course he thought about it but here this was a
very a very very nice way to do this is taking
here taking the knight first making complications
and tal is the king of making complications for
his opponent this is why he's my favorite player
i love to create complications and tactics guys
and this was awesome to actually see it be takes
a 4 ft g7 rook g8 bishop f5 guys knight takes h4
and we got into this position where he went
on to win the game and this guy's was example
number three now let's move on to example number
four the next example we have isaac berbreger
versus mikhail tao with the black pieces there was
a benoni defense from before the opening here we
got to a very wild position what else would we
get with plane tail so we have a wild position
here as we see this pawns this knight's hanging
right here the queen looks like he's locked out
this bishop's over here this it's just wild this
is what you expect to see when you're walking and
you look at tao's board and you're like oh yeah
typical towel position rook to g2 what happens for
black hair he actually takes on f3 queen takes f3
doesn't care about anything here maybe you can do
stuff like bishop to h3 and there's all kind of
things that can happen here he just takes on f3
and says forget it and then you know what instead
of even taking a knight he didn't want any trouble
there he just says oh knight d2 tao i'm not gonna
i'm not playing that game with you i'm just not
so he plays queen to e3 here now still threatening
stuff like f3 this check could be deadly as well
there's many things that can happen and after
queen to e3 there's knight to f1 now he goes back
and says i'll take a draw queen f3 knight d2 i'll
take a draw yeah i'm not going through all those
complications with you town yeah i'll take a
draw here now with black to move guys as he's
thinking and contemplating should he take this
draw what actually would you do in this position
instead of taking the draw here instead of taking
the draw tao was like you know what day is it what
time is it it could be like you know what yep it's
that time and then he sacrificed his queen bishop
takes g4 didn't even think about it it's there on
the board bishop takes g4 and then knight takes f3
bishop takes and now this is crazy this actually
doesn't even look like there's enough compensation
but in fact there is after bishop takes f4 there's
h4 on the board now of course the the things that
were happening is this could be a thing like
you almost don't have many defenses to these
kind of things also bishop moves bishop takes
c4 so maybe doing this doubling playing rookie
five doubling the rooks here and playing like
rook to g5 especially if bishop e2 moves i mean
look at the tie down i mean he's so miraculous
at tying down pieces to be able to do only one
thing and one thing only so after bishop takes
f3 there's h4 on the board and then rook to f8
and then we'll make a few more moves here to show
you guys what happened bishop to e2 knight g3 king
h2 and then he takes on g2 and honestly guys he
went on to win this game let's check the next
the next few moves look at that queen's back hey
thanks for the queen appreciate it bro takes takes
check check and bishop f4 and actually he went on
to win this game guys but back to the spectacular
moment here instead of taking that draw you can
always look for that advance now of course i've
been i'm not sure if i'm talking to anyone here
watching the video but you know sometimes you push
on and you lose a drawn game but here this is tau
this is how it's his time his kind of sacrifice he
sacrificed the queen saw that he had compensation
for it how much compensation it's also the shock
factor over the board that he took into account
to of not being of surprising his opponent here
and it actually worked out in his favor here so
this was example number four of the top five queen
sacrifices by tau now guys let's look at the final
example now in this last example guys we have
roman taran albero versus mike altao guys this
last game was actually a reverse sicilian here and
which was in english so it actually started with
one c4 now in this position guys of course it gets
scary it's kind of weird it looks like white's
doing fine here but also black has the bishops
here but it could be deadly because of the center
you just don't know it's just a wild position as
we always see with the towel here now after queen
to d2 rook 2e8 is actually placed here putting
some pressure on this knight but also the bishop
so you know roman realizes what's going on and
plays knight g5 because we're going to check right
here and would let you let you do whatever you
want like we're going to check you right here it's
going to be bad when we follow it with knight f7
unless maybe it might not be he actually said rook
takes e3 whoa come and get me brooke takes c3 come
and get me and then he plays bishop to d5 check
now guys what do you actually do here what do
you actually do pause the video can you find the
next two moves here after king h8 and knight f7
what do you do what do you do guys kha knight f7
so are we going back to g8 what would you do are
we trying it again but here's what happens tell
actually says i'm not doing any of that queen
takes f7 i'll take that one too my good friend
i'll take that one too from you he didn't care
about it yeah i moved my king to the corner knight
of seven at this point we now have a bishop and we
have a knight for the queen that we're sacrificing
after the queen's gone bishop rick to d3 first and
now bishop to d4 check there it is hit the man
with the move here very nice look at the play
here it's going to be very scary this was the key
move it seals the deal this rook to d3 followed by
bishop to d4 check king is here we don't want to
go to the corner because there's mating threats
that could happen so we need to have an escape
square so after king g2 95. now we're getting
everything into the play here bishop to g4 is
looking nice rook here followed by some checks
wow look at how all the pieces work together in
great harmony very harmonious way to play after
sacrificing a queen here now after work to d1 rook
to e3 queen f1 there's a check and then there's
rook to f3 and this game is already over guys this
game is already over here this bishop's hanging so
he's gonna try a few moves here queen e2 just to
defend and then after bishop f5 he just resigns
bishop at five the game's completely over here i
mean after king to h4 i think the best move here
is actually bishop e3 followed by g5 is that what
the engine says i think i think that was the uh
the lines here um from from looking at that you
also have king g7 followed by h6 and g5 there's
some a few moves you can play here but i think
bishop e3 is actually the best and it is it is
because this bishop is hanging so bishop b3 and
bishop to g5 or h6 g5 kind of stuff and putting
a bishop on g5 will be mate bishop e3 h6 bishop
g5 looks very nice here you have many ways to win
and of course tal went on to win this game guys it
was an excellent way of of sacrificing a queen and
following up with powerful moves let's look
at that again back here guys back here reverse
sicilian everything's going fine white's defending
like he's good he's doing great oh nike five
i got him guys you know i got him and then busy
rook takes e3 he's like okay yeah i mean i'll give
you that i'll give you that and then check and
then he takes it and you know probably his eyes
got huge here he took it then you have to realize
i'm playing tao so then he just relaxes and just
like well i'm just going to have to go through
the motions at this point bishop takes rook d3
check and then 95 oh my goodness and the game is
completely over after a few more moves guys this
was the top five queen sacrifices from mikhail tao
the magician from riga and my favorite player guys
and i'm national master james canty the third
with chess.com i hope you enjoyed the video
make sure you like and subscribe here at the
channel guys and i'll see you on the next video